irène chagnaud propos ce voyage sans
passeport cette émission est réalisée
avec le concours de monsieur bouton et
de solange péters monte à josette
romanet sont jean-claude du moulin
illustration sonore bernard de ronceray
et
laotienne
en haut
non
vietnamienne
chinoise
japonaise autant de beauté jaune à
travers ses charmes au visage un peu de
géographie
le laos est au centre de l'ancienne
chine le vietnam est maintenant partagée
en deux la chine comprend la chine
continentale et l'île de formose
quant au japon depuis la fin de la
dernière guerre il a récupéré presque
toutes ces îles
ici nous sommes à saigon saigon conserve
toutes ses traditions malgré les
coiffures moderne les examens et les
robes courtes que l'on rencontre un peu
partout et c'est à une de ses traditions
que nous vous convions
et
où
de saigon quelques heures à peine pour
rejoindre hong kong hong kong et mais
des dieux cette île est une des plus
belles du monde
compromis entre l'impérialisme
britannique et le communisme de mao tsé
toung 3 millions d'êtres biffures et
rochers adossé au géant chinois
hong kong plaque tournante de l'extrême
orient
toutes les races se croisent entre les
façades cossu du monde des affaires et
les balkans surchargé de la chine
éternelle
non
deux civilisations entraîner dans le
même tourbillon foule grouillante de
l'asie où les contrastes joue ici plus
que partout ailleurs en raison de la
densité des réfugiés et de la présence
encore officiel les occidentaux
c'est de l'autre côté de l'île dans un
village de pêcheurs que la chine reprend
ses droits
les hommes vont à la pêche et les femmes
travailleuses et fidèle trouve bien des
moyens pour faire entrer quelques
dollars au foyer
ici l'on vend de tout et l'on récupère
tout rien ne se perd rien ne se crée
tout se transforme
je pense
votre
montant d'aupic
on
en bas deux mondes s'affrontent deux
mondes se tolèrent deux mondes
coexistent la péninsule n'est séparé de
la frontière rouge que par les nouveaux
territoires sorte d'antichambre où tous
les réfugiés de l'ouest attente de
pouvoir être amalgamés aux privilèges de
la cité
mais il faut redescendre sur la terre
des hommes et vivre au rythme des
servitudes créé par leurs besoins si
l'on retrouve la main de l'angleterre
les filles du céleste empire ont su
adapter leurs costumes millénaire aux
exigences de la vie moderne sans lui
enlever son charme
et pour
oh
à
vois tu
un milliardaire chinois il en est là
aussi s'est offert ce jardin
oh
non
mais il est temps de misère en ce monde
qu'il est je crois sage de se demander
si la tour de sept étages réservés à
bouddha cache un dieu satisfait
ouais
nous voici sous d'autres cieux yokohama
somport le tout à une demi heure de
tokyo ginza équivalent du quartier de la
madeleine mais à tokyo
cette foule et comme dans toute ville
importante esclave de sa circulation
intense
pays surpeuplé où les traditions
millénaires voisinent avec les derniers
perfectionnement de la technique
en quelques heures on peut par le train
électrique aller à kyoto qui fut
capitale impériale entre 794 1868 tous
les éléments qui composent kyoto
s'enchevêtrent dans un délire de verdure
king à fuji pagode d'or ce pavillon
servait à de riches mécènes pour offrir
à leurs invités de marque la cérémonie
du thé dégâts que jy pagode d'argent
ce temple et vermillon cette couleur est
réservé aux temples shintoïstes et plus
particulièrement au temps que l'on
vénère le vieux renard inari qui
symbolisent les récoltes
la fontaine d'eau lustrale où l'on doit
se purifier en se lavant les mains en se
rinçant la bouche
les longues louche de bois appelée mythe
harrachis portent gravés au flanc de
caractère qui signifie coeur et
purification
après tout ces lignes d'une pureté
suprême l'oeil cherche plaisir et repos
dans le raffinement de ses jardins qui
de fines pénètrent au japon par le
truchement du bouddhisme un parc de 700
hectares abrite plusieurs tentes et en
particulier celui de kasika mangoro le
temple des dix mille lanternes avec son
tories des prêtres shindo east se
consacre à la prière et assure
l'entretien de culte avec l'aide des
milk aux filles des dieux qui sont à la
fois servant des prêtresses keira et la
danse la plus spectaculaire de leur
dévotion dans sacré dans les évolutions
lentes et hiératique sont scandées par
un orchestre religieux invocations
action de grâce aux dieux du shintô en
particulier à hama et rasent une déesse
du soleil que seul le chant du coq fit
sortir de la grotte où elle était cachée
non
les tories ou portique que l'on
rencontre à l'entraidé temple shinto
représente perchoir du coq sacré voici
le temple mende auront le temps pour dix
mille lanternes allumé deux fois l'an
elles ne sont en réalité que 3000 elle
brille pour la fête des diables ont
février et la fête de la pestilence en
août
l'inexorable droits de la vie reprend sa
loi des bars ou lien fragile
m
j
lannion
pis
dans ses usines dans les docks dans les
chantiers le japon moderne travaillent
jour et nuit pour faire vivre ses 87
millions d'habitants
malgré la fumée noire des machines les
mains des filles des dieux feront encore
longtemps montait vers le ciel les vols
vers le ciel les volutes par fumée de
l'encens